[Music]
to me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're so gay hey guys hope you're
enjoying the not gay --jared origin
stories that will be unfolding here for
the entire episode listen really quickly
for those who are not mug club members
watching on youtube for some reason
YouTube's decided to no longer notify
you or even put these videos in your
subscription box if you're not already
member lot of credit um slash mug Club
or at least bookmark favorite this
YouTube channel and go check it that way
you can
[Music]
[Music]
keep one handy so that's good to have
you haven't you sound guy by next week
glad to be with you it's the sound of
the weekend producing to me in video
studio as always as Jared who is not gay
follow them on twitter at not get here
and meet us cry over the comments cuz
thought your photo shops I fulfill my
legal obligations jarring conclusions
are we good we good have to get to it
wow necessary contractually @g Morgan Jr
simplified wine commies a sommelier
what's the one of the day get a little
red scooter here voyage and perform like
you want to be a red schooner with a guy
so we have Gary Sinise Dean deserves
more than boom it's kind of a rather
became bro that's bra bra bra I don't
know when it goes to next the orange in
stores now question of the day by the
way this is will get to the
trick-or-treating socialism Donald Trump
jr. tweet JK rowling Stephen Colbert one
thing you know obviously people know
that you tend to get more conservative
as you grow older in sometimes because
you have more skin in the game but I
want to ask you if you're watching we
have a lot of young people in the
audience as you've grown old or right
after Halloween do you find yourself
caring more about merit and less about
fairness is that a big part I think that
is for me I think when you get out of
college everything is about fairness
things about equality of outcomes and
once you've earned something unique to
you something that nobody else can earn
also you're going wow I this isn't just
a merit this isn't just a trophy
everybody gets this this merit thing
really means me yes so did you you
didn't do this yes you need to do all
this thing I either make rent or I don't
know right using your own value your own
skill sets what you bring to the table
so did you feel it as you get older
that's a natural progression that is
definitely been for me when I was a kid
I wanted everything to be fair yeah and
I I progressed a little earlier because
I just wrump you old main at twelve but
what's fair changes a lot too because
what's fair when you're younger it's not
saying the same thing is cuz me getting
what I earned that is fair that that is
fairness is Boppity no I think if you
wanna look at the surface fairness yeah
alright well we'll talk about that more
in the news floor living room an Idaho
credit union were forced to apologize
after this photo of him in blackface
surfaced the fact that Gerald laughs
right away
he's so as Facebook and Halloween by one
of the workers at the six poor women who
work at the p1 FCU credit union in
Lewiston who were apparently dressed as
the 1988 Olympic Jamaican bobsled team
made famous by that see that so that was
how they try to defend it people were
attacking and actually matters were made
worse when the creator of the costumes
clarified we actually weren't the
bobsled team just subprime borrowers
it's a very first one of the show aim
that flare gun right at your face Oh
Donna Brazile of course we have to talk
about the she's in the news this comes
from Mediaite she's been making the top
trends everywhere where she was she's
issued a scathing report on hillary
debbie wasserman the DNC at large
essentially she's just gone rogue she's
gonna party laughing birdie
it's like she's just feeling the Bern
it's like way so late like she doesn't
realize like it's done it's done
basically trying to burn the DNC figure
out of course is actually as we know her
second stab this week at relevancy after
quickly deleting her ill-fated and
widely met with skepticism hashtag me to
tweet a victim blame Friday the
Louisiana Supreme Court actually refused
to hear a suspects case today they
claimed there was no violation of his
rights occurring when he asked for I
quote a lawyer dog with the cops
claiming he asked for a lawyer dog
responds to suspect claiming that his
demand for a lawyer should have resulted
in the immediate suspension of
interrogation Scott Crichton penned a
brief opinion concurring with the courts
decision not to hear the case he wrote
the
defendants ambiguous and equivocal
reference to a lawyer dog does not
constitute the invocation of counsel
that warrants immediate termination of
the interview and this actually does
from salons of course have been cries of
racism judicial malpractice with one
opposing Disney producer actually
claiming there ain't nothing in the rule
books that said going retrievers can't
practice law black people do have a
harder I would like I don't buy in a
black you know black guys matter hands
up don't shoot but when it man I want a
lawyer dog that's why privileges are
talking about I get it I'll give you
that we put a comma in their lawyer
comma dog speaking I know just that's
what I mean I retama
it burns when I pee I need to cut out
Osama bin Laden was a huge gamer and
animate things insane so today the CIA
publicly released nearly half a million
files from his hard drive and it
revealed that he actually add a passion
for things like Resident Evil I think
was Mario and loads of Japanese anime so
people have now when you remember Saddam
Hussein they found him he loved The
Avengers and Raisin Bran from you yes
yet he was crazy for Raisin Bran crunch
they just they they hate America even
the stick yeah it is two totally
different cereal from raisin really yeah
I thought you were just making the
raisin breed you versus raisin bran
crunches candy cereal yeah totally God
okay but a son belongs parity was also
an artist himself as documents reveal he
was trying to get his comic series
published Tali bond got to kill them all
yeah that was no I don't want to take
off that one didn't take off and his his
venture into the young adult franchise
even less so hardcore tear as tentacle
pornography just didn't Japanese
appreciate straightforward marketing
there's no BS thing around the titles no
no no that's what market and they
appreciate it and they love them for it
plan and multiplayer with the sama bin
Laden
I got you he's gonna clan Taliban number
one it was just a stupid name Josh yeah
I guess well apparently also pirated a
lot of this game I think it was childish
thing for terrorists to have why would
he like that's ridiculous
no it's because the Japanese are also a
deeply disturbed dark people there you
go well kindred spirits Russian women
stripped naked in front of the US
Embassy in Russia to show their support
for Harvey Weinstein I know I first
thought am I reading that right so these
are the feminist protists where they
have to say they said we came here to
support the producer who offered women
sex the sex is right six is cool we're
here to say that when a man offers women
sex it is awesome it means you think we
are beautiful and sexy said another girl
this comes off on the heels of that girl
who is lifting up her skirt yeah a
feminist no skirt to protest groping in
a Russian train station their feathers
are different they're feminists are very
different from us and so to that we we
say we defect
[Music]
alright let's hunt for red october just
then yeah well you weren't it's a comedy
don't rest easy we still have a so
Donald Trump jr. tweeted something JK
Rowling retweeted it and then Stephen
Colbert decided to make it a part of his
monologue because that's what
entertainment is now on television so
yeah it is on here but listen soft
expectations this let's set it up this
is Stephen Colbert responding last night
Don junior tweeted a picture of his
young daughter holding her candy bucket
and said I'm going to take half of her
Canada tonight and give it to some kid
who sat at home it's never too early to
teach her about socialism yes it's never
too early to teach kids the danger of
sharing
yeah well litany of things that are
incorrect there the dangers of sharing
it's the old its it's the old adage but
you know there's nothing compassionate
about sharing somebody else's stuff so
if that didn't set it up for you where
you can hear that the rest of Stephen
Colbert's monologue will be mislead if
not misleading let's go into clip be on
Halloween kids literally go door-to-door
to get free candy from the neighbors
because the kids don't have it and the
neighbors do that socialism no it's not
no it's not that what why the kids
create or purchase costumes and for an
entire evening they walk door-to-door
tirelessly and they're rewarded for
their activity with candy that's called
work yeah the only way this actually
works is if that fat kid sits at home
does nothing no costume and makes
everybody come and bring candy to him
yeah it's the only way that's actually
socialism stuff looks like a little yeah
exactly in that fat kid by the way was
Bernie Sanders
now then Bernie change he started
counting points after his couch we're
done next clip no child in the history
of child antara Lee missed Halloween I'm
worried that kid didn't go out why is he
okay
is that child caring for a sick parent
you know it would be a nice thing to do
give him half your Halloween candy so
this is the quintessential leftist
argument right away they care and you
don't right they're compassionate when
you're not which statistically let's
just skip it couldn't be further from
the truth
okay Republicans give more to charity
they volunteer more of their time and
they give more blood not only that
Republicans are better tippers yeah
which we've written about of course
Bernie Sanders never kissed above 18
percent on the dot we wrote about that
was 15 I think it was 18% it might have
been 15 how the and to its credit yes 15
percent but it's very much like Ebenezer
Scrooge with the prisons and poor houses
I'm going to give the bare minimum and
not a penny more
exactly he says no child is willingly
ever stayed home on Halloween which this
is nothing it completely echoes again
the liberal idea of socialism and this
is an overarching theme that no one
could possibly be in poverty no one
would ever four go trick-or-treating
right if if it were within their control
it's closed off something they wanted to
do these are their victim of societal
circumstance where do they get this from
what let's go to Obama he said the same
thing all the time what we've long
understood though is that some
communities have consistently had been
odds stacked against them that's not
necessarily the thing that's always why
people are poor we also know some kids
who didn't do that right we know kids
who didn't want to wear a costume or
they forgot to make a costume or buy a
costume until it was too late and there
were always the kids were too clear
you're kind of a douche I need to treat
it in the college what's the matter with
that I trick-or-treat until I was 22
years old necessary joke 22 you just
have to get a full body costume and mask
and although you like to dress up you
just say you have a pituitary disorder
now if we get rid of the kid you know
who's going through Lukie going through
chemo who has leukemia
let's get her the extreme examples it's
far more likely that a kid isn't out
trick-or-treating because he chose not
to either because he chose not to
through inaction through not being
prepared or he just decided he wasn't
gonna go trick-or-treating he was gonna
rely on somebody else to do it the same
can be said for adults benefiting from
socialism good example Sweden were only
0.3 percent of refugees work had to get
that dig in their research study
concluded in the mid 90s the welfare
reforms actually could explain about 50
percent of the decline in desire to work
among non participants meeting people
who are not in the workforce so here's
that when you when you just give
somebody stuff I know it sounds like a
logical reach they just rely on you
giving them stuff next clip and it's
disturbing we need to be talking about
things like universal heath care which
would be a lifesaver for working people
socialist ideas outlined by the authors
of dots capital Karl Mars and Frederick
skittles or as you dum-dums like to call
them nerds oh my god now we don't call
them they called them communist copy
this hardcore
Karl Marx yes as a positive example you
don't want to do that and I was kind of
confused to threaten you know Frederick
any means fabric angles thank ya okay
who's the guy who helped the found
Marxist theory like who is this burger
guy and I realized oh this is like this
is like someone who's really in the know
of communist no spread drink well no no
it's no but it was bad because skittles
like killed Mars you kind of get but
skittles but was that great candy bar
barbar come on ripped off in the US I
can't find them very easily really yeah
true story that's replace Emma Snickers
always we have a slightly bigger Cadbury
egg in Canada so you get the short end
of the candy stick but it's crazy to me
he uses commas and the fact that then we
found out I think he means Frederick
angles like look if we ever made a joke
about Hitler that seemed to be praising
we'd be pretty clear you would realize
it
this is not satire and the fact that he
says you dum-dums in other words you can
be dum-dum tonight like the founders of
carnies because you dum-dums who don't
like chocolate Himmler like you'd be
like if someone said Hitler gummy and
then starts praising the generals and
Hitler he just say Hitler and Himmler I
think he sure Stephen Colbert is pro
communism was destroyed the world a
couple of times over and they never were
whose past it please they also never
worked no no never get beyond the
horrible ideology that resulted in the
hundreds of millions of people killed
yeah they were the douche who couch
surfed who never actually paid taxes or
work the job so just on a personal level
but Karl could you could you just leave
your stiff socks in your own drawer all
right
would you starch them we know what's
happening because when I go to work you
have time by yourself I know you're
writing your latest novella I mean total
losers this is crazy to me that people
have skimmed past Karl Marx yes yeah
this is what they left us they just want
to claim the moral high ground and give
people stuff but they fight they
consistently fight any policies that
would actually help the chronically the
perpetually important so they'll fight
for 15 yeah you sign up for fight for 15
which anything by the way
turns out yeah because they never I tell
you where they're gonna be and what
they're doing when they get these
pictures that's right down the block
from down the block yet twelve people
and they claim that was 35 I get emails
all the time you could tell they reach
out for like the really black names to
sign off on the letters it's really
obvious like it's not really they go out
of their way to make them something
really sad so the left they'll fight for
15 they'll fight for a bigger welfare
state more money for schools health care
to fight poverty Michelle Obama wants
you to get moving right to be healthy
move it but they oppose drug testing for
wealth there they opposed working for
wealth there and hell if you even live
an active healthy lifestyle guess what
you're still gonna have to pay the
skyrocketing premiums for someone who
lives in a diet of Snickers and funnel
cakes
hashtag no fashion really if you
actually look at you want to help people
get out of pocket and consistently fight
the tools that would do so if
we really want to help solve poverty
okay which is what the whole Colbert
thing is premises you don't care about
the poor it's only okay avoiding poverty
is pretty simple
ben shapiro has talked about this we've
talked about this for years finish high
school don't do drugs get married and
stay married not only will you not be
poor but the statistical likelihood of
your kids being poor as Nexus the
statistical likelihood of your kid
finishing school going to college
getting a job getting married where the
ends up in prison is or mommy and daddy
married and his daddy's still in the
house okay how dare you make sense that
requires a moral judgment people are
perpetually poor because rather than
tell the truth the left gives a handout
yeah yeah the truth is if that kid
didn't go out door-to-door again let's
disregard the extreme examples right the
kid who looks like Charlie Brown
progeria okay fine we'll give him
anything he wants okay he's gonna get a
make-a-wish you're gonna fix ice bars
get it but it's gonna be charity you're
not gonna steal it for me to give it to
him right that's a good volunteer yes
but most kids just didn't go
door-to-door for that candy okay fact is
he doesn't deserve it and your virtue
signal a little compassion doesn't
change it let's give you two scenarios
okay scenario one all right that kid who
didn't get the candy right seemingly
versus just give them the candy kids
bummed that I didn't get any candy and
he turns it around for next year
scenario one says no I really I really
know this was bummed this was a bummer I
should I should go door to door it I've
missed a lot of fun and candy next year
it gets a costume hits the road big year
two trash bags full of candy scenario
tis that kids bummed that he didn't get
his candy okay so he stays home instead
a parent steals it from some other kid
and gives it to him because compassion
and that parent promises him that he'll
do the same thing next year and the next
year and the year after that what do you
think happens to that kid worse what do
you think happens to the kid who
actually went door to door hit the
pavement only to have half of his stuff
taken and he knows that you're going to
take half that stuff next year and the
next year and the next
eventually that kid is going to give up
and that's this issue this this fake
fake victim culture though how about the
nice thing is just give the kid the
candy it's free this is when I was a kid
I remember we were do someone said you
know if you want to donate candy for
kids who are less fortunate now someone
said you want to donate candy to kids in
other countries cuz they don't have all
the Wayne fine I never was a kid I
turned to my father they say you know
kids in neighborhoods you are less
fortunate I turned to my dad and I said
it's free you can go out and get the
candy all you have to do is walk you
just have to walk even if you if you
don't have a costume put a bed sheet
over your head not if you're in a really
bad neighborhood in Detroit maybe that's
a bad idea
yeah I'm fine till your dad's clothes
dress up as an old man it's really it's
free
yeah there couldn't be a more perfect
example this is a great example when a
leftist says well you know what the
right thing is just to take it and just
share that candy what do you think when
they're taking something that's earned
for free right and that's they're
willing to do it with something that's
earned for free what do you think
they're willing to do with something
that's actually earned that isn't free
meaning payment for work your goods or
services or your business how far
they're willing to go in that instance
because when it's free and available to
everyone they still feel the need to
reassure you think it'd be like okay
listen guys all right yeah we'll take
this stuff because just go out scribe in
a few doors you don't need us to do that
for you do yeah they still say the right
thing is to steal from this guy and give
to you that's what the question of the
day do you find that as you get older
yeah you were gonna oh and here here's
your ex Mia Bella bought this video the
most is I get the metaphor of kids kids
understand candy they don't understand
money they understood wealth I thought
my parents have unlimited dollars and
cents when I just go is she in fact when
they bring up stuff in the grocery store
and you bring up one candy but $4 19 and
they do bring up another one for and it
said don t know I thought I thought this
is calculated total like if it still
says darn team let's just keep sitting
here all day what the hell are we doing
right but this is it kids understand
candy yeah but I also understand
metaphors can break down at some point
right to me when I look at this and
think okay Colbert went after a tweet
from Donald Trump jr. about a metaphor
that we all know can break down some
point this tells me he really has
socialism on the brain and really wanted
to get just an opportunities that he's
been looking for it hey writers any
opportunity to pluck socialism have you
got any opportunity is there open door
there has presented itself because I
really want to get to socialism he's
passionate about socialism this just was
happened to be as Avenue and really hope
when their Halloween specials where I
finally get to fit in my love for Karl
Marx
play coy I don't wanna know I really
mean all right we gotta get going Gavin
McInnes is coming up next and cousin
Dean Cain I think would be good
[Music]
we should leave him his dignity this is
the most ridiculous thing I've ever seen
foul mouth homo
he said homo he said homo can't you
understand English he said Oh No yeah
the closet that's Jared's home Garrett
[Music]
Jared oh whoa
Jared Oh mom
Jared's a homo he's just a home
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright that was called that was gonna
dance but hopper said he wanted to set
head but you know what he did today we
took him to the vet to get a bath ah he
walked right in I'm not joking
picked his leash up in his mouth and
walked himself right out the door like a
man just walked out walked out he picked
it up in his mouth and walked us to make
a statement all right come on it hasn't
actually that long a probably on more
frequently now that he is also done with
the Mudd Club members in the CR TV get
off my lawn Gavin underscore McGinnis
McGuinness on the on the Twitter's how
are you Gavin
I'm good how are you Steve I don't know
what crowder is this your uniform now
with this I mean is this like what you
wear for the show always yeah I have
about seven of these ties and about ten
of these shirts and it's my new look
it's my new thing
dad the decision is this in your mind
this is how most dads dress all my
decisions happen in my mind that's one
of my prerequisites yes they have to
involve my mind at some point down the
chain do you picture dad's like this
ideal dad NASA
okay also Michael Douglas I'm falling
down but you know these are the kind of
dads who I remember my dad I'm actually
gonna have them on my podcast tomorrow
would just like remember in the 70s dads
would do things like reap we book set up
a wall with bricks and stuff in the back
garden yeah wearing this like they'd
have their slacks on maybe an undershirt
but still they get cement on their dress
shoes yes the only shoes they had but
you know actually I've talked about this
a lot my grandfather a french-canadian
grandfather he used to get suits from
the guy who owned the properties he was
a super guy was mr. mojo was like a
millionaire which is unheard of in
Montreal so he'd give hand-me-down suits
to my grandfather he'll be walking up
three stories with two cans of tar
three-piece suit Brylcreem Clark Gable
mustache and he'd also be happy to be
elbow deep in shape he was doing
plumbing in any wood but he would still
the three-piece suit he'd keep the vest
on and you know we try to find
comfortable clothes for traveling so now
now dad's can't wait to get into their
peepee Jam jams the second they get home
the chute comes off like it's Superman
in Reverse
and no no Superman in normal and then
they've got their basketball shorts on
their bare feet like they're they're
going to their kids game and flip-flops
and and some undershirt with their
armpit hairs everywhere
yes everyone looks like they're in a
pajama party these days it's true they
look pretty gross by the way do you know
who directed falling down with Michael
Douglas a lot of people won't get
business do you know I believe it was
Drew Barrymore's mom what no I just made
no surprising because he's never made
another good film Joel Schumacher
directed that no really rubber nipple
Batman Joel Schumacher he directed
falling down you lost yourself judge
number 23 lost boys super gay undertone
to every film but he did falling down
and it's and it's great I don't know how
I don't it doesn't compute okay wait why
no some more juicy gossip yes I do you
know who wrote falling down Drew
Barrymore's mom strange the strange bald
pervert in Portlandia who has an obese
wife and they get up to all kinds of of
polyamorous lovemaking
he's peas portrayed as a hippie pervert
in Portlandia old guy can we get a name
I guess I can get listen you're a New
York guy it almost seems like years ago
at this point the New York terrorist
attacks in a career area what was that
like were you in New York when 9/11
occurred EB Rose Smith EB bees his first
system yes I was in I was here for 9/11
I was in the Lower East Side watched it
happen live watch the collapse became an
Islamophobe that minute right um still
passionately phobic to this day but I
was also in New York when the other
terror attack happened just two days ago
now right eight people were killed in
9/11 so did it change your perspective
when this happened now that your dad and
you're seeing it unfold
totally totally because I think a lot of
the childless no offense Jared and
Stevie but they they have less skin in
the game and they tend to sort of go wow
this is a bad way
or this is a bad month but but if Islam
gets to say over 10% of your population
you become a Sweden and you become a
Luton England and you become a country
that has a predilection or an area that
has a predilection to terror which is
dangerous and horrible and scary and it
is even worse for the next generation
Mohammed's a number one baby name in
England right now because they weren't
paying attention to it right and I don't
want that for my kids or my grandkids
what was it like having to explain this
to your to your children because
obviously there's a lot of
misinformation when it came out how'd
you just come out right and say listen
Muslim Muslim guy kill people cuz it
isn't like people who aren't Muslim
there are people out there who just hate
you because you don't share their
religion and it's evil how do you how do
you I don't like I said I don't have
kids how do you explain it to them
do you I know why don't you have kids
what the second you have that kid that
dog you have is going to become a
stuffed animal I look at my dog and I
just think die go ahead and die or don't
die I don't care just don't defecate on
my rug I feel nothing for him that's
private you haven't trained the dog to
not defecate on your rug I'm not saying
it's up to children a piece of furniture
yeah at this point really I mean he's
mine positively inert so he's easier to
handle but how old are your little ones
10 nine and four okay so here's the deal
with you when you have kids you you say
how do you explain 9/11 you avoid 9/11
for as much as possible it's like sex
it's like Santa it's like race you don't
want to discuss that you want the kids
to be kids for as long as possible
so the only time I bring up any of this
stuff is when they get told the opposite
by some blabbermouth yeah a church or
something like when they were told on
Martin Luther King's birthday that he
was killed by a gun and if only we could
pile up all the guns in the country and
have a big bonfire dangerous yeah
actually Marty loved guns they were not
yeah that is a lot of guns and the
general concept of flammability yes
start no be a few wooden but stocks but
the most part you're just gonna have a
lot of hot gun what a hot gun than some
melting lateral evita bullet to
smithereens as a
and it blew up on him yeah with a hammer
the hammer one knows a cat's answer so
you haven't talked about you haven't
talked about this with any of your kids
yet because basically the media is a
blabbermouth they lie about all of it so
the kid shouldn't be reading the New
York Post I mean action they go how am I
supposed to tell my kids what the
president says when he says grab your
[ __ ] or whatever and I go don't let
your kids hear what the president says
don't let them read the paper I hit that
I hit the newspaper when we had the
terror attack two days ago and today I
don't want them seeing that that's
folded it facedown on the kitchen table
no I'm pretty well either a they can
physically reach at the kitchen table
they have an iPad that doesn't worry you
at all but they just you know open Apple
news oh gosh kids don't have a news show
on CR TV they're not interested in news
of the day they're interested in FG TV
my son's interested in the Mets my
daughter's interested in making videos
on musically and chatting with her
friends I mean that we keep politicizing
the apolitical and that includes
children and it's it's a plague because
yeah only the very well-informed should
be dabbling in this area it's it's
dangerous for the naive to get involved
and the naive is heavily involved boy
it's true although in Montreal we're
just talking with this I took Jared for
the first time they remember these two
have the the porno tabloids next to the
skittles in Montreal he beat a dead body
porn and like Ring Pop how lay it out
I'll open this and they'd have a
stripper with her throat slit just like
that on the cover right what's like
Mexican tabloids and you walk by it as a
kid and go oh I didn't know that an open
throat look like that you can really see
the esophagus right I'm 31 years old
even though I'm 10 as a hyper sexualized
City like you'd have that you're KB toys
right next to a massage parlor and it's
like jeez yeah Lord is really was it was
populated by [ __ ] I mean the soldiers
went down there to kill all the Indians
who killed the Jesuits and then they
said all right we won this time the
Indians didn't beat us up but now we
need chicks so Louie the $0.14 they feed
em wah which were all the prostitutes
and you end up with a pretty [ __ ] City
but it's so [ __ ] and
sex-positive that you go to a strip club
and there's no seediness it's just like
Bonjour I'm a woman who's very
libidinous and I like to show my
genitalia to strangers and then the
strangers are like and I like to look at
genitalia so we have a fair exchange and
you're like what is this a hippie cult
yeah you're supposed to feel dirty in
here this is not fun anymore
it's a hippie cult where the
prerequisite is sounding like Lumiere
from Beauty and the Beast apparently
yeah okay so this happened is it just me
or did the media move on in record time
what happened I was enough yeah look at
Charlotte's ville or look at Vegas and
how it dominated the a hundred percent
of the show for at least a week I was
supposed to be on Tucker actually when
Vegas happened and it delayed us like
eight days and then they said ah we've
moved on to other things sorry that
could have just been an excuse but the
point is that that both of those things
were seen as week swallowers right this
we feel like we're doing ancient history
now and it was two days ago
yeah cuz Dustin Hoffman grabbed an ass
that was a surprise I was stunned to
discover that Brett Ratner was a jerk
who knew who knew that Kevin Spacey
millionaire homosexual in the arts
groped buns yes I know that was one I
will say it in tandem together hmm we
don't know could be a lone wolf when
they did know the guy yelled out Allahu
Akbar as you said you're nothing good
happens after that we don't know
combined with Hey breaking news Kevin
Spacey's gay as though they didn't know
this all along
it completely destroyed any shred of
integrity I felt if the media had loved
I mean you know even Amina Tim everyone
knew he was gay I'm gonna get on a plane
I'm going to open the window the
emergency window I'm gonna get on top of
the plane with a bullhorn and I'm going
to announce to all of North America the
difference between these white lunatics
who kill people and Muslims is the
Muslims are following a book yeah it
says it in the book there's a pattern
with one and no pattern with the other
under sermon yeah oh Jesus you mean when
I'm wiping a nail that town
Blazing Saddles challenges it's like
that Kim jung-un village put it we made
a three from yeah it is it is remarkable
I understand it right you're trying to
look for a correlation okay mass
shooting is there something instead they
ultimately come back to an inanimate
object we were telling I don't know how
else to explain it
we talked about this yesterday book says
kill gays women are second-class
citizens kill non-muslims or treat them
as second-class citizens
every Muslim country in the history of
ever that's what they do case in point
why is this still an issue I don't
understand it gets so repetitive you
wonder if that's why they move on but
they don't move on they move on because
they want to say hashtag not all Muslims
and I want to blow my brains out well
they also they hate white people right
so they go okay
to criticize Islam feels like I'm making
fun of brown people I don't like that I
want to focus on the Charlottesville the
Vegas ones you go okay I get that but
the guy who did this was white he was
part of when Russia sort of got
encroached by Islam and now he have
leads all as Zeca stands that have white
dudes with big funny beards you can hate
him he's all there for the aiding if you
still don't care yeah no I don't I don't
like it i they always say I've talked to
liberals about this now let's go
that's not my area of expertise and
that's that happens in the other part of
the world and I go no it actually
happened in the West Side Highway bike
paths in lower Manhattan right next to
you so what is your issue and then you
had you had liberal journalists saying I
know I live in New York but the odds of
that happening to me are a fraction of a
tenth of one percent okay good okay so
well wait until the odds are one in
three right you're gonna have your heads
blown off before we care about Islam and
the West
I live in Alphabet City I don't go that
high I don't know that I'm safe
it's also Keys you have to like wait for
the wait for Islam to conquer the entire
United States and become the man before
liberals have a problem with them that's
the thing though it's like saying hey
listen I really have a problem with
Denmark socialized health well what
about the what about the people from
Denmark I don't care about the most
talked about
the ones in Denmark let's talk about
where they have power in every Muslim
country ever they want to talk about sis
white patriarchy let's take the most
moderate Muslim country in existence
they still flog you in and don't need
you for dressing you modestly and you're
exempt blocking for these alright Gavin
where's the best place for people to
find you and watch this show we're gonna
have a promo here later today as well
okay there's a website that called CR
tv.com you go on there and you'll see my
face I'm the one that has a beard just
click on that and then I will come out
of your machines shade throne that's at
Gavin underscore McGinnis another couple
months before we have him back we have
Gary Sinise he's a nice man it'll get
better
[Music]
on now for barely legal with Bill
Richmond sponsored by my club
hi I'm bill Richman the half-asian
lawyer for louder with Crowder here to
help dispel myths and clear up confusion
regarding commonly misunderstood legal
terms today we have a question about why
is it that sometimes a person will be
cleared of all criminal charges and yet
still face a civil lawsuit aside from
the technical differences of differing
standards of proof in different remedies
perhaps the most common thing is is that
despite the fact that johnny is never
coming back
that family still once those dollar
dollar bills for louder Crowder choose
this has been barely legal with Bill
Richmond sponsored by mug club hey guys
go to see our TV comm right now and
check out get off my lawn it's a
libertarian Family Values show where we
talk about free speech on campus the out
laugh drugs gun sex and why conservatism
is the new punk rock politics is two
types of people people want to be left
alone people who won't leave us the hell
alone if you're part of the first group
welcome aboard
if you're part of the second group then
get off my lawn
[Music]
all right next guests love to have him
but we always have we always have some
trouble figuring out questions because
he's possibly the nicest guy that's a
problem met and so usually this show
we're dealing with news there's
controversy we're like hey could we ask
him about oh no he's just gonna he's too
nice to ask that question it's like it's
like asking a really nice uncle brie
like I don't I don't know that he knows
about that story because on facebook.com
slash Gary Sinise so in case you hadn't
guessed who it is yet mr. Sinise how are
you sir how are you very nice thank you
for the introduction very nice now were
you always this kind of a man or did
like just did society pummel you into
submission that's my question as someone
like you born or were you made what do
you mean by this kind of man so so nice
all I don't think I've ever seen you
raise your voice you've always been so
welcoming to people who I've seen you
interact with fans but that's not
typical of everyone I've met in
Hollywood so is that just your nature
well I've got I've got a lot to be
thankful for how things have gone things
have gone pretty well we've got a great
three kids you know been married to same
woman since 1981 you know things have
gone well the career has gone well there
you know I've been blessed still have
both my parents haven't been I haven't
had any major tragedies personally in in
my life that have you know really taken
our family into difficult situations
like so many families that I actually
work with through my foundation and
through the support work that I'm with
I'm seeing people constantly that are
you know going through some very very
difficult challenges so I just feel kind
of kind of blessed and thankful for for
the good fortune I've had see that's
exactly what I'm talking about he looks
like he looks like 20 things that he's
grateful for and complements to everyone
and none of it was like none of it was
like the kind of Trump for Hollywood
like and I'm the best at
that's a question how what only you and
Alice Cooper have been married that long
of anyone I know in the entertainment
industry it is incredibly rare what's
the secret to that cuz I've got to
imagine even you like get mad every now
and then right you're married it happens
my wife is very very funny she's got a
man eccentric person so even after 40
years I'm baffled at some of the things
that that she says and comes up with and
they're very very entertaining and very
amusing so I think your sense of humor
is something that that can carry the day
look we like any couple who's been
together a long time you've been you've
had your challenges and we've certainly
had ours but you know I'm blessed we're
still together we've had some issues you
know she's she's suffered with some
terrible spine issues she's had six back
surgeries and and survived those and you
know we've been through our challenges
ourselves but you know what we've out on
top we have a faith and and belief and
it's it's helped carry us carry us
through a lot of good things and a lot
of tough things as well well there you
hopefully some people listen I don't
thinks I need there are many people in
the industry who will not but him and
it's very similar actually Alice
Cooper's answer he said me my wife has a
great sense of humor and you know you
have to be able to work through these
issues he did go through rehab though
serious issues and just said to Lina my
wife is the ultimate so Alice Cooper of
all people you would know is the nicest
guy no one has a bad word to say about
him look how about this Gary because
this week obviously listen your industry
has taken kind of a pummeling right it's
been in the entertainment industry has
been on the radar of a lot of folks just
needs to improve in hockey anyone's
going Gary in hockey we have some
actually you know we have some friends a
good friend of our family's for a while
with Stu Grimm said he was an enforcer
they called him the Grim Reaper nicest
guy a lawyer a lot of the time the
really most aggressive players would
surprise you and be the nicest guys who
are some people in the industry who you
would
most people will be surprised just a
great all-around you know family person
you're never gonna hear a scandal about
them oh I have a lot of good friends I
mean one one of my oldest dearest
friends is Jeff Perry who's on that show
ironically he's on a show called scandal
high school together
we started Steppenwolf theater together
with our buddy Terry Kinney Jeff you
know he's the father of Zoe Perry who is
now on that new show young Sheldon she
plays his mother right and her mother is
Laurie Metcalf you know they've been
through their challenges and things like
that but Jeff is just one of the most
wonderful guys who've been been like my
brother for for over 40 years going back
to the early 70s so wonderful guy
you know his head's on right Joe Montana
is another great buddy of mine who
really is just you know Wonder wonderful
guy very charitable giving person very
you know these are two guys that grew up
in Chicago I mean we all grew up in
Chicago together so you know we have a
history there how do you avoid the
accent though how do you avoid the
Chicago sound like did you did you have
to work on it when you moved out there I
didn't grow up in the city Joe has a
little bit more of that because he grew
up at Cicero right but Jeff Jeff and I
grew up in about 25 miles north of the
city in a town called Highland Park jerk
which is you know upper-middle class
Barry and there's a big Jewish community
there you know Barrack you know I didn't
know anybody who thought like that you
know next to Dennis Farina yeah I got it
hey well here's something cuz I know
you've worked it Dennis was a good pal
of mine yeah I got the note back in the
80s yeah I've heard really good things
about it some that surprised me
obviously these allegations came out
about Dustin Hoffman but when I was
reading the journals this lady was
talking about not just Dustin but all
these things that went on but she talked
about she said I am in love with John
Malkovich she said I love the way he
orders lunch
she had it would surprise me because
john malkovich is an actor who was kind
of known for that subdued rage right and
when you see this coming it's a perfect
example of I know you've worked him with
him would you corroborate super nice guy
this lady was in love with him she said
he was the just a consummate gentleman
yeah John John you know he's very
eccentric and funny and I think he plays
you know he plays a character a little
bit because it's entertaining and people
are used to that and they expect him to
say bizarre and entertaining things and
stuff but John's a very very nice guy
we've known each other back since the
70s he's him he's a member Steppenwolf
theater going back to the mid-70s yeah I
remember that I just finding it's so
telling where this lady was running and
she went out of her way to say I love
the way I could listen to John Malkovich
order lunch all day and not a like well
I felt awkward because you could have
been teen teen mr. sneaks up for like a
like know he might be know so but we
don't know no John someone who's a
stand-up guy sorry go ahead yeah let's
talk about John any more otherwise get a
phone call Gary I told you never to let
my name leave your lips alright he's
gonna throw a Coke it you know you work
with uh you just got back from your
soaring the soaring valor flight I think
it is right yeah yeah so you do a lot of
work with the troops and go over how
when you build these smart houses and if
people haven't checked it out you know
like I said go follow on Facebook you
can see everything so if you fix a lot
of concrete real-world problems you
don't just do a photo op and he's busy
doing good things
busy doing really good things when I was
a kid and I was a troubled youth a
little bit and I went to a counselor he
said know if you're busy you don't get
into trouble do you think maybe that's a
part of it you're busy focusing on
helping other people it okay it's it's
tougher to get into some get into some
riffraff well it's it look services is a
great healer I remember you know many
times being heartbroken over over
different things you know meeting lots
of our wounded service members back back
in the 90s working with Vietnam veterans
in the 80s who had been
you know had had been shamed when they
came home from war and the feeling very
you know compassion for them after
September 11th feeling that I needed to
do something to reach out to the men and
women who were deploying in reaction to
that and getting hurt and you know the
families who were losing loved ones and
everything so I just started to serve
and to use this blessing of good you
know this good fortune I've had in a
movie business and television business
to to do some trying to do something
positive and it's growing into a
full-time ongoing life mission to give
back to the men and women who serve our
country I get a great reward from being
able to do that and I've had some great
success you know moving television
business not not only the you know the
being a well known you know of around
the world for CSI New York or whatever
it is the the TVs and TV shows and
movies but you know the financial
rewards have been have been good and I'm
able to take some of that do some good
with it start a foundation the Gary
Sinise foundation do some good and I
know I get a lot of a lot of good
feeling out of that so I'm spending all
my time trying trying to try to do that
I know there are people in the business
who have made you know it made a good
living they've you know and I would
recommend you know using some of that
good fortune to do something positive
for somebody else and it's a it's a good
it's a good feeling to be able to do
that I feel like I'm about Bill Murray
and rush Murrow
what's the secret max and I think that's
it I'm just talking about it we were
talking to off-air going you know it's a
lot of actors a lot of people industry
just don't age gracefully they're trying
to recapture something or be someone or
not and I think that's what it is the
way to age gracefully in all aspects is
just okay this is this is my chapter
where I'm going to esteem others first I
have the ability to and Gary doesn't
that's a Gary Sinise foundation we do
have to get going it's facebook.com
slash Gary Sinise a lot of guy who did a
lot of great work and we'll keep
shouting it from the rooftops because
Gary often doesn't in quiet so we can do
it for you Gary I know you won't say it
but thank you so much for being for them
I appreciate
you have spread in the word is also Gary
Sinise foundation.org that's the
foundation website we're doing some good
on mom leaving next week to go down to
Texas we're doing a big concert in
Houston to support first responders that
were affected by the hurricane there's a
hurricane relief fund on the on the
website there's all kinds of good things
there I mean I just jumped at the Gary
Sinise foundation I hate to cut you off
but that's the sound of a bump come on
Gary Sinise foundation.org we'll be
right back after this
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey there handsome no not not you Oh
Lord no I'm talking about that snazzy
t-shirt looks like someone's been
dropping some coin at louder with grotto
shop calm now come near let the world
see don't be shy there we go that's what
I'm talking about oh no someone's trying
to be a sneaky fellow let's go we're
that bad boy loud and proud nothing to
be ashamed of here hey what's the big
idea
stop kidding around and show everybody
your swag don't make me come down there
well now your t-shirt just says
socialism which is far more embarrassing
there we go see nothing to be afraid of
available exclusively at louder with
Crowder shop calm mug clubbers are
almost never beaten up for wearing a
long-sleeve socialism is for [ __ ]
t-shirt unless of course your sickly
looking and lacking self-confidence and
that's why we now sell long-sleeve
versions perfect for those cool summer
nights and covering up a lifetime of Jim
avoidance and for decisions get yours
now with Lada with Grutter shop calm
that's Lada with brother shop calm
because anywhere else would be pure
[ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello thought it was called a viewers
helper here don't forget the new
coalition to the podcast on the go on
iTunes or SoundCloud on the audio you
can download it and you condition it and
[Music]
that list of its it's pretty good I'm
pretty good terrifying when a girl looks
you in the face hey our next guest loved
him hate him we all wait you you you're
almost different but we love him he
always makes it work at real Dean Cain
Dean Cain how are you sir I am great
good morning guys buddy what's up buddy
yes good morning for Dean because he
lives by night so what we're just on
during the break with the Wendy Williams
pass out and I know we all feel terrible
but oh my god once I find out that she
was okay that is one of the funniest
things I have ever seen okay first then
it's good to laugh yes like if something
happens to your friend they're going
along and then afterward you can laugh
about it but yeah it was there are a lot
of moments in that very short period of
time
yeah there's the initial the wave wait
some subs go wrong okay and then she
thinks I got it she looked like this the
skin when Tom and Jerry when he did when
Jay jumped out of his skin okay but it
was pretty funny and I would be a liar
if I said I didn't watch it at least
three times and call people over to look
at it what now she is she competitive
with the with the Today Show and that
time slot we watched on oh I sense I
don't think she is she's a little bit
later in the afternoon I think no but
you know that today shows a juggernaut
it is the Today Show's a juggernaut
when's the next time are you you're
going to be on there people need to know
I don't know the last thing I did
actually was host a Fox & Friends
weekend that was kind of interesting oh
did you make any weren't sexually
harassed no no no I was waiting for it
hoping for your annual bonus in the
bonus of it Trump didn't know who you
were before he does now there we go
well actually I know mr. Trump I the
president I know him because I judge the
Miss Universe contest years ago that's
right we talked about that you should
know this I should know these things
hey speaking of which do any of these
sexual harassment things surprise you
right now going on I mean obviously this
is the main story like to me that what
really bothered me about the news with
the Kevin Spacey deal was the media
acting as though they were shocked that
he was dead but ever learn the industry
has known this for years it makes me not
trust you know New York Times and like
breaking Kevin Spacey's game you just
now are not trusting the New York Times
blog yeah but you know I had to pick one
at that point well yeah it's it's one of
those thing I said it's the worst-kept
secret in Hollywood that was a that's
something that you hear all the time
like the Weinstein bit you hear all the
time Kevin Spacey being gay was subs you
heard you know I've never seen Weinstein
do his thing
I've never seen Kevin do his thing I did
go to a premiere way back 25 years ago
and it was a great one I figure where
the film was but Kevin Spacey talked to
me all night I was like he's the nicest
guy in the world am I just like yeah we
talked about Kevin no I do want to [ __ ]
God touch it touch it
play what tell me you love me the guy
they would fall prey to that I don't
think no I can't we were talking about
this before you came on I can't imagine
you sexually harassing anyone because
you're Dean Cain you can walk into a
room say sex with me and six hands will
go up immediately three people accused
of groping as someone on Fox News on air
in a lawsuit which was the most
frivolous thing I've ever seen in my
life
unfortunately it was on air so nothing's
ever it's the most ridiculous that's a
scary thing can we not say the name
because it is on air people know if they
run a search it was it was I don't want
to throw anyone under the bus but it's
very obvious I'm rottens Google search
Dean Cain it was okay there was
there was a co-host the same bhai he's
saying goodbye was this outnumbered well
if he missed yes oh by the way first a
Fox News sets it up right they're all in
the leg Sharma
now there's a lot of that that went on
at Fox News I'm not defending all of it
so I don't want to I don't want to lump
everything in the same category here but
in this instance Dean said goodbye to
one of the outnumbered co-hosts and get
really kissing the cheek
she reached out and that was it what you
do in Europe all the time it's what I've
done with that same person 50 times yeah
you're not even a thought process but
that was called groping by an attorney
and I thought that was hysterical
about that too that people will because
somebody had to think well what about
your alleged say I'm like really thank
God it's on on-camera so does it I'm not
saying that you know anybody who accuse
anybody of anything is line imagination
but there is - it's a two-way street
sometimes and with today's culture it's
like you know you're gonna get the
public turn on you really quickly and
everyone's gonna jump in you've been
allegedly accused and that's a scary
thing for someone like me that's I was
stunned you could have thrown a brick at
me I could have passed out on the Wendy
Williams Show is lose for her - the girl
- because now is now all the angry
[ __ ] are bad that she got a kiss from
he came all pissed at her and it really
is you can go watch it I remember I read
it and I'm washing like this is I can't
believe that this woman would pick
something that was so clear on air just
say it happened behind a closed door and
people will believe you because that's
what happens but it's like this is on
air it's a peck on the cheek yeah so
that's a concern for me too because
Weinstein is everyone kind of new in the
industry like I've never seen it but
I've known people who've worked them
it's pretty well known on the flip side
there's the me - campaign we're now it
also is trending you're going on a
second nine out of ten of these cases
now have no evidence so it's different
with Weinstein and Spacey and they
admitted to it but now it's just like
this guy - and and James Woods and he
shut that down really quickly but I mean
how do you how do you handle it it is a
tough balancing act that's a tough one
and right now certainly the the current
trend is toward you know whoever's you
know if your blame for your horrific ly
guilty but there are a lot of people
there are a tremendous number of people
in Hollywood especially vinner that are
tremendously guilty people in power been
doing this for ever and and there's no
about that but I'm glad it's come to the
forefront I'm glad there's not these you
don't have to see the joke's on South
Park and go oh is that the truth and you
know you mentioned some of that stuff on
South Park and things and they have fun
with her or Seth MacFarlane saying at
the Oscars and right things we all know
and in effect but um but I'm glad it's
finally come out it's just shocking but
it's you know suddenly now house of
cards is canceled and this is that the
other thing I'd say but you've known
these things this is no surprise that's
what bothers me for you now you're
rocking the black the v-neck there if
someone comes out you see you again just
say it wasn't me it was Simon Cowell
yeah hordes of men saying the city was a
guy who would him look at you and like
rub his nipples slowly in the green room
or something you know you read the work
log but yeah it sounds like something
you would do yeah just cut him up -
wha-what he's in the trailer yeah it is
a one thing we're talking with us
yesterday yeah I know you're more
conservative fiscally and socially
liberal now that being said personally
you're not a guy who's like socially no
concert note no boundaries I know that
about you
because Hollywood though is for a long
time just just reviled middle America
and if so much shows up who is a
Christian in the film or is abstinent or
is actually you know it is loyal to
their wife they're secretly the serial
killer right Hollywood has facial
themselves always so open minded and
sexually progressive I'm going how is
this any surprise that this is this is
an entire segment of society that prides
itself on immorality and chastises those
who criticize them like it couldn't go
any other way
no um you know he's looking real good
right about now Mike Pence yeah well not
have dinner with it when the woman is
not my wife just what I wanted there
that you cannot get accused of all the
things that he may or someone else may
be accused of right and shooting
feminist be on board because a they're
like no water you can't control himself
no but he knows if drinks are had
inhibition sometimes I removed there can
be other accusations so to remove any
liability and to also ensure that
there's no scenario in which he could
sexually is so even if you think he's a
germ he's a germ who's removed any
opportunity to act germ like and the guy
just now got run through the wringer
wait I just want to have their cake and
eat it too and by that I mean they they
like lots of cake pitches for madly been
sexually harassed and gone after a bump
but it doesn't I don't go at home at
night and cry my pillow and like oh my
god okay give us a name now no God the
list I mean I mean it goes on it all day
no came on this week he was like a
Versace yeah it was that's he tried to
touch my pecker Versace was that Versace
I would imagine that's up no no never
had a gay man do it that just wouldn't
that probably wouldn't go over so I mean
he was sexually harassed by the models
he worked with on set he was sexually
harassed by females never drive a car
again all the slashed tires a part of me
wonders this is just this is entirely a
hypothesis you can tell me there's
something to this now you were a very
successful athlete Princeton obviously
you just didn't go watch his highlight
reel now you compare that someone it's
always been a good-looking guy
compare that with like someone like
Dustin Hoffman the recent accusations
came out the reason I use that example
is because it's it's pretty in-depth and
no one involved has denied any of it
thus far or Kevin Spacey so these are
people who probably had great difficulty
achieving you know attention from
members of the opposite sex until they
became a part of the cool kids club
which was Hollywood and so they come in
to it and now all of a sudden they've
been given this platform and this this
power that they never had and do you
think that maybe they're the ones who
are more likely to of use it worse for
you you've probably had to since college
be aware if you're at a party anyone
could accuse you because it's like
that's Dean Cain on campus you know you
get a sexual harassment suit on that guy
in you're set for life I would say
that's extremely accurate no question
about it yeah there's no question so
that only doesn't just apply to
Hollywood that applies to politicians
right I
really applies the politicians hungry a
lot of those guys Wow
my gents would not have a hard time that
you know getting any poonanny in indiana
if he wanted to so he's had training in
saying no just let your head training
and saying no where's the other one just
going give me give me give me I need I
need you know absolute truth and it's
men of power for a lot it was you know
abused their position and it's women of
power it doesn't just happen just men I
mean it happens it happens on both ways
that's it it's much more prevalent for a
man to do it but it certainly haven't
seen teachers on time teachers all the
time yeah yeah it happens with teachers
female teachers a lot and that's a
horrible thing that never happened to me
I see Steve is like that's a heart I
just can't imagine I would imagine every
single teacher
Dean Cain put an apple on their desk
they're like thank you let's talk about
it after college every team's trying to
put Dean Cain on layaway sort of
situation but it's it is pretty damn
prevalent and it has touched my family
to some degree not myself right but it's
been it's an unfortunate thing so that
does certainly does exist I do think
what's mostly other guys you know it's
the guys we talk about the guys who
maybe couldn't wouldn't be so certain
you know socially popular and wouldn't
have maybe the luck with the ladies that
that I've seen right people that I know
who were in this business and who do
that they'll just call it an actress cuz
they think she's beautiful she has no
chance to get the part they just want to
meet her yeah it happened plenty I have
seen that happen as well as a matter
fact in Montreal there's one who I won't
name a name but it wouldn't be that hard
for people to figure out and it was it
was kind of well-known listen in the
realm of actors I'm like I would be like
a five in the realm of stand-up
comedians I'm beyond a 10 okay on the
road and just connect MIDI or pick it
see you're out and you know Hackensack
New Jersey roof and so this happened a
lot when I was in 1819 and I'd be doing
stand-up all all the time opportunity
was there all the time right you have a
giver you have five shows that weekend a
room of 200 people okay
all the time either trying to follow me
to the Hoff in the hotel room is is it
right next to the club I had like no
listen you know especially if especially
when I had a girlfriend now not in the
next guy the guy would be the headliner
would
hey I'm having a party over at my place
and invite them into their room and so
it was really different this was a guy I
remember a guy bald old fat typical
comedian unhappy
I remember facially again said to be
saying hey I had a bit about not being
boyfriend route material she wrote me a
note on a receipt and said hey I think
you're boyfriend material and I thought
look it's kind of squeeze like you know
what I have I have a girlfriend thank
you but then she followed me she was
pretty aggressive and she was attractive
mind you so it wasn't very easy for me
to say no as a 19 year old male at this
point and this guy was very creepy and
he pursued her I don't think he was
successful but I just thought that was
like oh wow this guy's never learned how
to be no not right now that's that's a
muscle you kind of have to exercise
self-control no question about it you
can get in that awful lot of trouble and
you see that with a lot of people um
there's no question I I have stayed
pretty scot-free and I've certainly
dated in my day life for a young man I'm
still very young very very young and
we'll see you know I I'm sure at some
point I mean if I ever run for office
I'm sure someone will say I did
something awful terrible I cut their
hair back in grade school or you know or
I did already dated somebody's sister or
friend or whatever I'm sure that will
all be you know look he's trying to
soften or he's actually done psyche what
he really means is he slept with
someone's sister while his friend was in
the house and that's gonna come out and
it's gonna like I'm running for Senate
and I have to apologize for this I think
we're past that though
oh they were passives yeah I think my
past the era of like I mean everyone guy
who's gonna run for president in 15
years is gonna have a you know Yahoo
Messenger screen name yeah you know I
mean that's just course there's no way
around it now
oh yeah I kidding people found my Zynga
host
programs going down great because you're
the only non Asian on Jenga Kevin Spacey
like sure if someone came out and said
yeah Dean Cain had a casting couch they
would go and I think Dean Cain needed a
cast and could be the reaction alright
you say where's the best place for
people to find you and follow you at my
house oh wait don't do that don't
that Hatfield Dean Cain on Twitter I've
been most active on Twitter and I have
an Instagram account but I almost never
use it it's true because all the ladies
chasing too much in the Instagram
account and then he has to fend them off
and say no Weinstein's here no we'll be
back after this - there it is again so
strong
[Music]
[Music]
oh you have to go
[Music]
[Music]
I'll be writing
Oh
[Music]
but that's my house yeah
[Music]
I let them die while I made a makeshift
snorkel hmm
clever here's your lever drowning dance
coughs could be gotten arts pass
Duquesne always fun really smart guy did
you ever watch his highlight reel drill
the highlight reel Levine came in
Princeton no no I heard he was a good
football you never watched it no oh wow
I think you for not reading them I think
hold up one time and it was it was
pretty impressive I don't think I look
like an angry little jumping bean not
that big plate for Stanford Princeton
person it's not I think it wasn't I
think it was on the bench for not for
like the Raiders or something went on
bills for the bills I take it all back
you can play for a long time too I think
it was kind of like a no but it doesn't
matter you get in you're an NFL guy
that's a big deal
is it yeah Oh doesn't mean I must be at
a certain level yeah yeah absolutely
ya know everybody else is packing it up
and you're keeping going so right let's
cool he was also at 511 you know 205 11
make it to the bills yeah not a big guy
well not big bills Super Bowls is they
always the first couple drafts no people
like you know you get the second draft
pick but you just said have you ever
lost a super Wang four times in a row
the bills are you kidding you don't know
that souls are stupid well I don't
anyway I don't is a good football player
so going back to I did not play tight
Inferno today thank you very much
where's your Teri Hatcher [ __ ] treating
and the social isn't like civilizations
for ever have known that if you don't
work you don't eat
all right it's just it's built into us
it's like you have to tell a child to
say no you don't have to tell them to be
selfish you don't have to tell a
civilization that people have to work to
survive right why are we all of a sudden
kind of teams it's like parenting a lot
of parents and they're just they're
chasing their kids like listen your kids
not gonna run into the fireplace unless
he's really stupid in which case you
should probably run in there anyway I
mean like parents like oh yeah I feel
like yeah kids inherently parent since
the beginning of time they didn't know
they didn't just watch their kids every
second they their inherent yeah things
the kid you learn information
I think it's fight two because liberals
probably I think I think they see
working less and socialism as ever
that's that's the evolution right that's
the yeah from like work lease are but
you don't realize like people had people
were dying for they realized he needed
to work that was what well you know
evolution was looking to eat and I don't
want to seem Darwinian at all you know
in the sense that like well it's just if
you didn't eat because we had villages
but we had villages in the sense that it
provided some level of protection some
level of course of a safety net where
you realize there was strength in
numbers but if other people were out
hunting and foraging and then you you
just ate it and sat in your ass all day
no there was no Stephen Colbert with a
late-night you know T P monologues and
berries right no I'll bring up my book
of Alec Gong Qin punchline position that
sat around and did nothing and survived
so we can't but they're committing
suicide in an alarming been carrying
them like listen let's just let's just
be Darwinian and just think about the
natural laws but here's the thing
conserve as we talk about this a lot
when we need to change my mind we
believe in not only natural laws but
natural rights because natural rights
are often found in some form of natural
law natural rights mean it's a it's a
birthright in constitutionally that
means it's recognized by God you may not
believe in God but hey thank God your
rights aren't given to you by government
they're given to you by God and the
government's only job is to protect your
natural rights so the thing about
obviously is a Christian what we believe
the morals that we put in place but also
the free enterprise system it's a way to
guide natural rights to be as effective
as it can be that as we recognize that
listen people inherently they're gonna
they're gonna fend for themselves people
who Forge and hunt if if you let them
reap what they sow they're gonna go out
and they're gonna benefit everyone in
the village they're gonna bring back
that woolly mammoth they're gonna bring
back that bison and everyone else gets
to eat he might charge you or he might
have you working for him but that guy
went out and he led and so the way we
create a system the free enterprise
system the capitalist system is a way to
harness the best of human nature
natural laws whereas you look at the
left and I do mean today the the
regressive left the left like Stephen
Colbert who quotes Carl Mars bar really
Carl Marx and Frederick angles you look
at communism what's the trend is trying
to fly in the face of natural law which
is why they don't believe in natural
rights they don't believe in your
god-given right to freedom of speech
they don't believe in your natural right
your god-given right to
self-preservation the Second Amendment
and so they don't really have a lot of
respect for natural law they said no no
we know that every civilization is the
beginning of time you eat what you kill
so we're gonna change we're gonna change
that we're gonna force people to be
charitable never has that happen
successfully we're going to force people
to ensure equal outcomes never has that
happened successfully in a way that's
benefited the entire village it's maybe
benefited the committee's those people
forcing now I'm talking about the
village but socialism Marxism communism
has never benefited the globe as a whole
as capitalism free enterprise a
constitutional republic of the United
States has no society ever has and it
really does come down to this is what I
was talking about and I hope to see a
lot of answer to the question today I'll
try and talk with you guys on YouTube
about it the idea of merit over fairness
because for a long time when you're
young you think about fairness of
outcomes equality of outcome the left is
still stuck there Bernie Sanders who's
never worked a day in the private sector
in his life that's why he still believes
it you're hard-pressed to find a single
business owner who believes that anyone
out there and then we have some people
who watch this show like I just had
someone recently was a world
powerlifting champion like hey this is
what I do I can't really talk about it
publicly but yeah I really appreciate
the show we have some people who are
really elite in their fields anyone
who's ever achieved something great in
any realm of the human condition whether
could be athletic it could be physical
it could be emotional it could be
spiritual it could be financial
anyone who's achieved a level of
greatness understands the amount of work
that went into it understand that the
big difference is the follow through
following through if you if you've
gotten really good at a sport think of a
hobby darts right the big I found in my
life where I've been somewhat successful
has been alright committing to something
and following through that's how you
probably get good at guitar that's
probably how you get good at golf the
thing is people tend to follow through
on things that are hobbies because it's
fun it's easy to follow through on
something that's still fun but following
through on something when it's no longer
fun well see that's where free
prai's actually encourages you to go
against against the worst part of the
natural human condition yeah natural law
is eat what you kill
yeah natural law is okay we're on our
own but if you follow through if you go
that if you innovate if you create
something you're going to be rewarded by
the village because that's something
that they need the big differentiating
factor and we don't like to acknowledge
this often is the follow-through when
things aren't fun running a business
creating a cure for polio by finding new
treatments for cancer creating the
Internet I guarantee you there are
points with every great technological
advancement medical advancement or every
great contribution to American society
that we can think of there was a point
where it was no longer fun just like
your sorry little ass didn't want to get
out when you were 12 years old and go
trick-or-treating but you realize it was
one of your last prime years and you
felt bad and you tried to get it back
you didn't feel like doing it so you
didn't follow through well free
enterprise the capitalist system unlike
socialism unlike the Karl Marx who
Stephen Colbert praises acknowledges and
validates and rewards the follow-through
which is what makes great people so do
it in your personal life look at areas
where maybe you put something off maybe
I hear they're gonna be do really well
at this if I only finished that follow
through and I want to be a part of a
society that actually rewards the
follow-through I want to be a part of
the society the United States that has
made every other country better for it's
like Wayne Gretzky Wayne Gretzky's great
skill I'll leave you with this Canadian
Wayne Gretzky great skill was he wasn't
the best shooter he wasn't the best puck
handler he said he wasn't the toughest
guy but he made everybody on the ice
better for having been on there the
United States is the Wayne Gretzky of
the globe
no country clump comes close every other
country has benefited for us being here
and finishing the follow-through I want
to be a part of that society otherwise
we're just Sweden and that sucks see you
next week
[Music]